hi cosmic warriors my name is ELISA I am
an astrologer and today we are going to
be looking at the cosmic compatibility
between Justin Bieber Haley Baldwin and
Selena Gomez what I do every day is I
look at the Stars the natal chart is a
snapshot of the sky at the exact moment
of birth you can look at an anal chart
to figure out future events past events
everything you need about somebody is
embedded within your chart okay so first
and foremost I just want to set the
record straight that I am NOT a be bling
is that what it's called
I respect Justin Bieber I respect all of
these people but I do not follow them I
do not have preferences and I am NOT
rooting for any one person in particular
so first and foremost we have Justin
Bieber he is a Pisces son with a Libra
Moon and even though we don't know the
exact time of birth we have enough
information to deduce that he must be a
Scorpio Rising Justin Bieber is really
looking to find clarity to find wisdom
and to transcend this earthly plane that
we're in like so many of us and
especially Pisces which is such an
ethereal sign so this means that really
what is going on in his chart is a lot a
lot of water energy so Justin Bieber is
probably psychic so there is a cosmic
connection between these two people the
first thing that jumps out to me when
I'm looking at these charts side-by-side
is that their moons are in complete
opposition is really going though their
moons are in complete opposition these
two people are here to teach each other
lessons Justin Bieber hates being alone
you have heard it here first
interestingly Haley Baldwin with her
Moon in Aries the opposite sign of Libra
is the sign of me
so Libra is we and Aries is me and when
these two come together they're teaching
the other about themselves they are
having fun they're having the best time
of their lives together they are having
a blast they're posting about getting
engaged they
going out and they're probably gonna go
on like a fun island trip Justin's
Uranus is in Capricorn at 24 degrees and
her Neptune which is fantasy and
illusion and actually the entertainment
industry is at 25 degrees in Capricorn
Uranus is shocking things things that
come out of nowhere Neptune is the
entertainment industry so when we put
these together yeah we're gonna make
some big splash and we're gonna make
some big public statement that is gonna
rock everybody's world that nobody saw
coming and it's kind of like a little
bit of a view to the man regarding
Selena so I'm I do think that there
really is an interesting relationship
between Selena Gomez and Justin Bieber a
hundred percent their son which is their
ego their essence than their sense of
self fall in the 8th house and the 8th
house is the area of the chart linked to
sex death and transformation both of
these people Selena to Justin and Justin
to Selena are really really karmic it's
a really karmic connection that these
two people have and have had with each
other for a very long time I think in
that she also accepts the fact that this
is a relationship that maybe she needs
to let go of in order for her to reach
her fullest potential so final thoughts
on these charts after spending a little
time with them and looking at them I
think that there is a really important
purpose between Justin and Haley and
their engagement and what this
symbolizes to them while engagement may
mean something to you it may mean
something totally different to Justin
and Haley but definitely anticipating
that by in October 2018 we are going to
see them in the public eye again in a
very very big way in terms of Selena she
is a goddess she is absolutely fine and
I honestly think that she wishes them
well ultimately she's on her own path to
and everyone's gonna be great thank you
all so much for watching my name is
ELISA I am the author of the mixology of
astrology and I
see you next time in the stars
[Music]